[Musique]
ma première émission à la télévision
c'était décembre de police leur départ
c'était une série d'articles dans rock
et folk
on prenait des stars et on les
interviewés comme si elles étaient des
repris de justice s'étaient transformés
l'interview en interrogatoire en fait
c'est ma première interview formaté
alors il y avait l'un pervers le plus
pervers mon complice jean luc m et moi
l'un perd mastic le plus mastoc aurait
writing la 23e qui s'appelait l'impair
rose le plus morose on les interviewés
pendant quatre heures on leur parlait de
tous les grains de beauté de l'amour
l'argent la mort tout tout tout tout les
habitudes c'est et terry pour eux et
ensuite il y avait la photo de
l'arrestation et la photo de la ve marie
france brière qui était la directrice
des divertissements et des variétés à
tf1 adoré descente de police et un jour
elle me dit je veux que tu fasse la même
chose à la télévision
sauf que c'était pas évident ça a
commencé avec yves simon le chanteur etc
ciment on va chez lui à saint germain on
arrive chez lui et là on commence à
virer les livres de sa bibliothèque à
les mettre par terre la table yves par
terre ensuite on embarque on l'amène à
l'hôtel plm saint jacques on avait loué
une chambre ont rempli la baignoire on
lui met la tête dans l'eau pour le faire
avouer on frappe tellement qu'on lui
fait une côte basse était ce à quoi
c'était vraiment pâques
et puis le pire c'était karen shea karen
cheryl on l'avait interviewé dans
l'endroit où on tournait les cinq
dernières minutes dont il y avait un
espèce de de décor comme ça de flics et
on était là moi un moment je prends une
canette de kronenbourg jeu la casse et
j'avais ce tesson de bouteille comme ça
il lui dit tu vas parler
elle essayait d'attraper le tesson de
bouteille ce couple doit ça commence à
saigner elle dit mais si vous êtes
complètement con je vais en référer à
hervé bourges parce qu'elle travaillait
sur tf1 grâce à dieu
hervé bourges m'a pardonné pour ce coup
là parce que la fois d'après un jour
bourges est convoqué à la haute autorité
à l'époque c'était michele cotta qui
dirigeait ils disent mais hervé est ce
que vous avez vu
ce qui a été dit sur votre chaîne
vendredi soir sinon elle commence à lui
lire le texte le verbatim de l'interview
de jeanne mas c'était est ce que tu es
vaginale clitoridienne annales elle ne
répondait j'aime pas qu'on touche à mes
fesses c'était assez chaud pour dire la
vérité est là l'émission été supprimés
voilà donc ma première émission été
supprimés au bout de 6 numéros dans des
centres de police j'ai pas vraiment des
missions en particulier à vous
recommander pasquin a eu six ou sept
dont il faut tous les regarde et vous
allez voir c'est vraiment pâques et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de linars dit
yves abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux